a surprising character from 1883 has
returned to narrate the follow-up series
1923. here's why it's so meaningful for
Elsa Dunn to once again tell her
family's story spoilers for 1883 and the
first episode of 1923 ahead in the
Yellowstone prequel series 1883 James
Dunton and his wife Margaret ride from
Tennessee to Montana with their two
children Elsa and John nicknamed Jack
they make the difficult and arduous
Journey because they're seeking a better
life but by the time they arrive in
Montana many of their traveling parties
have died including Elsa while the
family is grieving the loss of their
daughter they decide to settle on the
land where she dies as it turns out the
tree under which she took her last
breath was also the place where John
Dutton warned the death of his oldest
son Lee in Yellowstone season one
viewers were devastated by Elsa's Ark
because so much of the series had
revolved around her many fans had been
convinced that after falling in love
with Ennis and losing her virginity to
him the family would discover she was
pregnant by the end of the season
unfortunately that wasn't the case
Ennis also died trying to protect them
Eric Nelson who played Ennis told TV
Insider we could have conquered the
world together but it wasn't in the
plans he also went on to praise the
realistic portrayal of the time period
adding we just see how quickly things
can change and so you can't take a
single second or day for granted also
narrated her family's perilous journey
to Montana in 1883 and she's doing the
same from beyond the grave in 1923.
foreshadowing what's to come for the
remaining duttons the 1883 season finale
ends with Elsa reuniting in death with
Sam the Comanche man she fell in love
with after Ennis died before the pair
raced through the planes Elsa's
voiceover explains there's a moment why
a dream sending memories March together
and form a perfect world that is heaven
Elsa may be gone but she isn't quite
done talking about her family or the
difficulties they face 1923 opens with
the same brutality that we've long come
to associate with the Yellowstone
Universe it doesn't waste time with
introductions instead immediately
jumping into the action we start with an
unknown man limping while he tries to
run obviously having been shot in the
leg we quickly realize that he's not
supposed to be on the Dutton land and
any sympathy we have for him dissipates
when we see that he's about to shoot our
protagonist Cara Dutton while she
screams in anguish after killing him
it's clear she's done this before Elsa's
voice over plainly states
violence has always haunted this family
reminding us that this sentiment is kind
of the dutton's motto Cara like the
duttons before and after isn't afraid to
do what's necessary for the ranch and
family from Elsa's voiceover we also
learned that her parents James and
Margaret had a second son Spencer before
meeting tragic fates of their own after
their deaths James brother Jacob and his
wife Cara took the boy in raised him and
built the Empire his brother dreamed of
viewers are given a major clue as to
what's to come in 1923 when Elsa States
my father had three children
[Music]
one would live to see their own children
grow while the season begins with both
brothers alive we now know one won't
survive the season but fans probably
shouldn't think that hint about the
events of 1923 has given anything away
Siri's Creator Taylor Sheridan is known
for taking story lines places no one
expects producer David glosser told The
Hollywood Reporter just before the 1883
finale aired it's never what you think
and the other shows we have coming up
this year there's never anything that's
on the nose Taylor believes in dropping
you right into a world and you're going
to be immersed in that world and
whatever you think is going to happen is
not going to happen
[Music]